economía en directo América de Francia
24 Daniela Blandón en nuestro estudio
Daniela vamos a hablar de Reino Unido
porque finalmente ya se presentó el
esperado plan financiero que recordemos
que fue este mismo el que acabó con el
gobierno del disfraz Así es Raúl le
llevamos esperandolo desde que se fue
listón
un poquito más de un mes pues mire el
ministro de finanzas Jeremy Hunt reveló
los detalles de este presupuesto de
emergencia de 55 mil millones de libras
esterlinas destinado a reparar las
maltrechas finanzas del país y que
incluye un alza de impuestos y recorte
de gastos ahora tratemos de desglosarlo
entre las medidas figura en la reducción
de la base sobre la cual se comienza a
pagar el impuesto sobre la renta más
alto que está en 350.000 libras y
quedará un poco más de 125 mil libras un
impuesto también temporal sobre las
ganancias extraordinarias para las
empresas generadoras de energía
aparecerá del 45%, y desde enero del
próximo año y hasta marzo del 2028 va a
aumentar ese mismo impuesto para las
empresas de petróleo y gas al 35% desde
el 25% en que está actualmente se
mantendrán Igualmente los beneficios
Fiscales para la generación de empleo
todo esto hay que decirlo está dentro
del marco de un reconocimiento que
también hizo el Reino Unido Y es que el
país ya está en recesión y su pib va a
retroceder probablemente 1,4% en 2023
Dani Y por qué entonces la firma
genéticas son las que financian en gran
medida este plan Bueno entonces lo vamos
a tratar de explicar mire los precios
del petróleo y del gas se han disparado
a raíz de la invasión Rusia
de Rusia a Ucrania eso ya lo sabemos
pero el costo de producir electricidad a
partir de gas suele ser el punto de
referencia para establecer el precio
mayorista de la energía que ayuda a
determinar finalmente cuánto paga la
gente por su energía es decir lo hagan
lo que cueste la generación eléctrica
con gas cuesta lo que vale la generación
eléctrica a cualquier con otra fuente de
energía como ese precio de gas está
altísimo eso significa que los
generadores de energía renovable como
son las plantas eólicas o solares y las
nucleares están beneficiando de Los
Altos precios al por mayor porque su
costo de producción energía es mucho más
bajo que el del gas entonces quieren
imponerles a ellos grabámenes para que
se paguen por este exceso de ganancias
vamos con otra noticia de la actualidad
Dani porque hoy se conoció también que
se va a extender por cuatro meses más al
menos el acuerdo de exportación de
granos entre Turquía sí Exacto como
mediación de Turquía uno entre Ucrania y
Rusia Dani Entonces por qué tan
importante este acuerdo de la
exportación de granos en el mar Negro
pues primero digamos brevemente En qué
consiste este acuerdo lo alcanzaron en
julio y participan como lo decía Rusia
Ucrania Turquía y Naciones Unidas
creó este pacto un corredor de tránsito
marítimo protegido para aliviar la
escasez mundial de alimentos al permitir
que se reanudaran las exportaciones
desde tres puertos en Ucrania que es un
importante productor de granos y
semillas oleaginosas este pacto del que
Rusia quiso retirarse en su momento
vencía este sábado pero fue extendido
por cuatro meses más hasta el momento se
han podido desbloquear un poco más de 11
millones de toneladas de productos
agrícolas vamos a ver en el gráfico Cómo
se ha distribuido esa exportación
incluyen cuatro o más de 4 4.5 millones
de toneladas de maíz 3 millones de
toneladas de trigo y otros productos
como semillas de canola y aceite de
girasol esto contribuye Dani a superar
la crisis alimentaria sobre todo en Asia
y África directamente que estos granos
van exportados así ya puedes mirar Raúl
la guerra si ha contribuido en gran
parte a la crisis alimentaria mundial
especialmente la que se vive en estas
regiones pero también todos los factores
como el de 19 y la sequía en países que
son grandes productores adicionalmente
este pacto del mar del Norte solamente
incluye tres puertos y no está el de
mico Life por el que antes de la guerra
pasaba más de la tercera parte de los
alimentos que se exportaban desde
Ucrania también hay muchos agricultores
ucranianos que no están sembrando o que
trabajan a pérdidas Y eso hace que
estemos lejos de ver un verdadero cambio
Rusia quiere a su vez que le
flexibilicen sus propias exportaciones
de granos y fertilizantes porque
recordemos que este país es el mayor
exportador mundial de trigo Pero ha
perdido mercado por las sanciones
occidentales todo esto combinado ha
repercutido en los precios por ejemplo
el trigo aumentó su precio
considerablemente después de la invasión
ahora está en niveles previos al
conflicto Sí pero los productos que se
fabrican a base de trigo si están muy
elevados entre otros debido a la
debilidad de las monedas y también los
precios más altos de la energía en todo
caso Rusia dijo seguimos con el acuerdo
pero tal cual no le van a hacer cambios
ni le van a agregar este puerto de mi
colegio y el señor que vamos a hablar a
continuación llegó Mejor dicho para
hacer cualquier tipo de cambios en esa
compañía Por supuesto estamos hablando
de ahí lo más que dejó estar
considerando un posible cambio de
presidente en Twitter aunque no todavía
este hombre que es el más rico del mundo
subió al estrado en un tribunal de
Delaware el miércoles para defenderse
dentro de un juicio del que ya hablamos
es un pago que le hicieron por 56 mil
millones de dólares en tesla algunos de
sus accionistas lo consideran
desproporcionado y que lo consiguió a
base de engaños Y gracias al dominio que
tenía sobre la junta directiva y no
precisamente por sus logros en efectos
se trató de la remuneración más elevada
de la historia para un ejecutivo de una
empresa que cotiza en bolsa pero y los
moscas defendió su labor dice que no
actuó de manera inadecuada Pero quizás
lo que más llamó la atención dentro de
ese testimonio fue que eventualmente
conseguiría un nuevo director ejecu para
Twitter Aunque aclaró que solamente será
cuando termine una reestructuración que
está llevando a cabo porque juntamos
Twitter con tesla porque los
inversionistas de tesla están cada vez
más preocupados por el tiempo que hemos
dedica a cambiar Twitter pues creen que
va a descuidar al fabricante de autos de
lujo bueno el día mire Entre 25 dólares
y 31 dólares eso cuesta en Japón una
botella del tradicional vino francés
boyoló nuvot dependiendo de quién lo
importe si el gigante cervecero kirin o
su rival sometery holdings porque le
estoy hablando de este vino porque
aunque bañarse en vino suena hoy como un
lujo casi imposible en este país muchos
desafiaron esos crecientes costos para
sumergirse en una piscina llena
precisamente de esta bebida Y es que
este vino cuesta hoy el doble que hace
un año debido no solamente a la alta
inflación sino también al debilitamiento
del yen que está los niveles que no se
veían hace tres décadas frente al Dólar
porque es tan importante Japón para esta
región francesa porque es muy es un
importante consumidor del vino francés
en especial de este boscherlo nubo
porque la región del mismo nombre
exporta esta nación la mitad de su vino
que son casi cuatro millones de botellas
por año Así que bueno habría que ser y
los mosca ahora para sumergirse
alcohol porque yo veo que ahí hay niños
bañándoselo están tomando
Dani como siempre Muchísimas gracias por
toda la información económica más
adelante por supuesto más economía aquí
en Francia 24 Así es Raúl volvemos
entonces después de un baño de agua no
de vino café